[Musique]
le west side story version steven
spielberg pourrait bien être le film du
temps des fêtes car les critiques sont
dithyrambiques et oui c'est un bon film
c'est un grand film c'est un film
machabulles le jettera de leurs droits
west side story à d'abord été une
comédie musicale en 1957 avant de
devenir en 1961 un film qui a remporté
des oscars
ce drame inspiré du roméo et juliette de
william shakespeare met en scène deux
amoureux aux prises avec la rivalité de
deux classes le est issu de la classe
ouvrière blanche et l'autre d'émigrés
portoricain
[Musique]
le nouveau film de steven spielberg est
très différent de la version de 1961
nous dit françois levac heureusement on
n'a plus droit à des acteurs blancs que
du fond de teint très foncé c'était
malheureusement une pratique courante à
hollywood à l'époque
a décidé de recourir à des acteurs dont
l'héritage latino-américain et
manifestent ce qui est une excellente
chose
le premier gringo qui te fait un sourire
le racisme est au coeur de la version de
spielberg qui s'est approprié l'oeuvre
selon michel coulombe le principe même
de spielberg c'est comme ceux qui
travaillent c'est pousser les curseurs
toujours d'y aller à fond c'est une
situation dramatique on veut en tirer le
maximum
avec une part de sentimentalisme puisque
rita moreno qui est-elle anita de 1961
fait une apparition dans ce film si des
critiques s'attendent à ce que ben saïd
story soit de la prochaine course aux
oscars en partie à cause de ses chansons
inoubliables mais surtout à cause de sa
condamnation du cercle vicieux de la
violence je pense que c'est un message
qu'on a besoin d'entendre aujourd'hui
au vu de tout ce qui se passe
l'actualité est un film émouvant prenant
et qui prouve que steven spielberg a eu
beaucoup d'instinct déclencher une
troisième guerre mondiale le film west
side story prendra la fiche de ce jeudi
ici vous chutez quimey radio canada
montréal
[Musique]